l'engagement de la france aux côtés des
chrétiens d'orient et pour côté des
minorités religieuses j'en reparlerai
c'est un engagement historique
on le sait 1536 je peux vous dire
revenir mais
et donc ce n'est pas uniquement une
réaction aux terribles exactions
commises par des ch à l'encontre des
chrétiens d'orient et des minorités
irakiennes et syrienne l'exaction
épouvantables qu'ils se sont développées
depuis 2014
ça donnait une image ans une visibilité
grave nouvelle mais je pense notre pays
a été au rendez vous ne serait ce que
par la guerre que nous avons menées et
que nous n'avons pas achevé peut-être
qu'on y reviendra
mais au-delà de cela la persécution des
chrétiens d'orient par les dialyses eu
le vent n'est pas notre seul motif de
préoccupation à leur égard parce que sur
fond de guerre sur fond de
bouleversements économiques sur fond de
discrimination de violence la condition
de ville les a poussés à l'exil dans des
proportions massives et c'est bien le
sujet central on a déjà parlé lorsque
j'étais venu la fois précédente
la population leur part de la population
globale de la région s'est trouvée
drastiquement réduites et que je
constate que c'est les populations qui
sont restés occupent désormais une
position encore plus minoritaire dans
les sociétés auquel il appartenait c'est
un mouvement de fond qui est
notre préoccupation centrale et il est
donc clair que leur situation ne pourra
s'améliorer durablement sans résolution
des crises politiques et des conflits du
moyen-orient on en a point sans doute
pour un certain temps on va y revenir
mais c'est quand même une de nos
priorités et si tu sais pas si j'y
consacre comme une partie de mon temps
mais ça ne pourra s'améliorer aussi sans
des législations plus équitable et des
politiques plus inclusive mais je
voulais rappeler ça parce que c'est
quand même le fond de de la situation
alors dans ce cadre-là concernant des
législations plus équitable et plus de
plus inclusive il y a eu des mouvements
que il faut souligner nos partenaires
cendres pour certains s'être engagé dans
cette voie je pense en particulier en
irak où noël est devenu par exemple jour
férié pour pour tous je pense en egypte
où le président s'y ci a décidé la
construction de la cathédrale de la
nativité du caire dans la nouvelle
capitale du caire qui l'avait ensuite il
a inauguré avec le pape de l'église
copte orthodoxe towers 2 c'est aussi en
en egypte que le président 6 6 a nommé
pour la première fois une femme copte
une femme copte à un poste de gouverneur
plus généralement les autorités
religieuses musulmanes sont nombreuses à
professer leur respect des chrétiens et
le devoir de respecter leurs droits
et ça je crois que c'est relativement
récent par rapport à ma communication
précédente
je les exemples je viens de donner mais
aussi le déplacement historique du pape
françois aux émirats arabes unis en 2019
et en irak en mars dernier à cette
occasion il a d'ailleurs rencontré la
principale autorité religieuse du
schisme l'ayatollah sistani a pas que
nous mêmes nous n'ayons pu
nadja nadjaf le rencontrer et je
témoigne aussi de cette mutation la
signature par le pape et le grand imam
de la meute de dalles de l'université al
azhar de la déclaration d'abou dhabi sur
la fraternité humaine pour la paix
mondiale et la création par ces deux
autorités religieuses d'un haut comité
pour la fraternité soutenu par l'egypte
et les émirats arabes unis chargé de
promouvoir la mise en oeuvre de des
objectifs de la déclaration
bon ça ce sont des éléments plutôt
positif au niveau de l'esprit
d'inclusivité malheureusement force est
de constater que bien des sujets de
préoccupation demeurent en dépit de ces
raisons d'espérer que je viens indiqué
je viens d'indiquer et tous beaucoup de
de créer les crises continue à nourrir
la pauvreté a suscité des violences et à
contraindre au départ nombre de femmes
d'hommes et d'enfants
j'aurais aussi rappelé dans des propos
généraux que quelle que soit la force
des liens historiques qui nous unissent
aux chrétiens d'orient les principes de
au nom desquels notre république
s'engage à leurs côtés nous portons vrai
aussi mais c'est aussi le le de la
dénomination de votre de vos groupes de
travail
et de deux
de recherche à oeuvrer pour la
protection et l'intégration de
l'ensemble des minorités ethniques et
religieuses de la région et notre action
sur le terrain n'a d'ailleurs que plus
de cohérence et d'efficacité dans ce
domaine et notre conviction c'est que la
diversité ethnique et religieuse est non
seulement une part constitutive de ces
sociétés du proche- et moyen-orient mais
également un atout peau pour leur avenir
et donc on ne saurait envisager la
situation des chrétiens d'orient ce sens
lié cette situation à celle des autres
minorités de la région je pense aux
eyzies dit je pense au shabak je pense
aux au bail je pense aucun pays
je pense aussi aux sunnites en pays
chiite et o'shea temps pays sunnites et
je pense aussi au delà des chrétiens
appartenant aux églises historiques qui
existent depuis 2000 ans au moyen-orient
à partie des chrétiens dont on ne parle
pas assez souvent qu'ils sont les
millions de chrétiens d'origine
étrangère venue dans les pays arabes
notamment dans les pays du golfe pour y
travailler et je pense aussi aux
personnes de plus en plus nombreuses
converti de l'islam au christianisme
souvent vers des églises évangéliques
donc nous sommes devons agir sur
l'ensemble du spectre pour pouvoir faire
respecter les identités et permettent la
diversité ethnique et religieuse alors
vous avez rappelé sera en 2015 que nous
avions la france et vert après avoir
appelé l'attention du conseil de
sécurité cette question au mois de mars
la france avait organisé en septembre la
conférence de paris sur la protection
des victimes de violences ethniques et
religieuses au moyen-orient le plan
d'action qui en est issu demeure notre
feuille de route tant dans son volet
politique dans ses volets humanitaire
permettent de retour en sécurité des
réfugiés et des personnes déplacées que
dans le domaine judiciaire
lutter contre l'impunité et nous
attachons aujourd'hui encore à ce que
les principes qui sont issus de cette
feuille de route soit reste inscrit à
l'agenda international
que ce soit la promotion d'une
citoyenneté égale pour tous l'éducation
la réinsertion économique des réfugiés
nous avions convenu d'une autre
conférence du même de même nature mais
encore davantage l'accent sur l'enjeu
d'une citoyenneté inclusive dans les
sociétés de la région c'est une autre
conférence de même nature était prévue
fin juin
enfin de me pendre fin 2019 et nous
avions passé des accords avec les
autorités irakiennes pour la co
organisée à bagdad et pour faire qu'il
ya un événement de portée internationale
qui puisse se développer à la suite de
la réunion de 2015 et c'était opportun
de le faire à la suite de
l'échec et la fin du clifa territoriale
de dèche et c'était significatif
symbolique à tous égards mais la
situation en irak nous a conduit à
repousser à plusieurs fois cette
échéance d'abord parce qu'il est le
mouvement de contestation populaire et
les violences qui ont eu lieu à
l'automne 2010 9 puis la démission du
premier ministre d'el mahdi puis
le remplacement en mai 2020 parole le
premier ministre casimir tout ça était
une situation un peu tendue il ya eu une
contexte des attaques contre les
emprises de la coalition qui se poursuit
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils aient eu des
attaques
hier soir encore à erbil contre deux des
empreintes des emprises de la coalition
à par drones quand même un peu un peu
inquiétant mais non on en parlait tout à
l'heure
il ya eu aussi ensuite l'élimination de
deux de race m sulejmani en janvier 2020
puis le contexte de la crise sanitaire
est désormais la proximité du scrutin
législatif du 10 octobre en irak des
élections anticipées
ce qui fait que moi je reste tout à fait
déterminé à l'idée d'organiser cette
réunion en irak
je pense que c'est le beaune le bon pays
au bon moment mais on ne pourra le faire
que lorsque la situation politique sera
un peu stabilisé que les conditions
sécuritaires aussi et donc c'est après
les élections irakiennes
souhaitant que ce passe bien que nous
pourrions envisager de faire un nouveau
forum cour présidée par les autorités
irakiennes cette aventure le premier ce
qui sera sortira des urnes soient prêts
à le faire mais je pense qu'il n'y
aurait pas de d'opposition pour qu'on
puisse organiser
assez assez rapidement tout comme je
souhaite je souhaitais vraiment pouvoir
être à l'organisation à la co
organisation de cette de cette
conférence donc nous avons cet outil là
qui est un outil d'affirmation politique
publique d'affirmation des principes
fondamentaux et or en même temps
d'affirmation de notre volonté de lutter
contre toutes les exactions et en
particulier contre la reprise des ch
on y reviendra mais je le dis tout de
suite pour éviter de l'oublier il y a eu
la semaine dernière pour la première
fois depuis longtemps en présentiel
une réunion de la coalition contre des
ch qui s'est tenue à rome avec les
principaux acteurs et c'était
indispensable que ça se fasse avec une
volonté de poursuivre le combat parce
que nous ne sommes pas sortis de cette
situation on voit bien que tout le
centre de préoccupation c'est l'irak que
si l'irak ne se redresse pas alors il
peut y avoir des risques de résurgence
de dèche et donc il apporte à la fois de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
pacification irakienne qui n'est pas
encore au rendez vous un accompagnement
militaire qui a été ré annoncées par les
différents acteurs y compris par nous
mêmes dans le domaine de la formation
militaire en particulier qu'il faut
qu'il y ait un redressement économique
indispensable et sans cela on verra
apparaître en particulier dans les zones
sunnites
le
les initiatives de d'âge qui aujourd'hui
dans la clandestinité souterraine mais
quand même très présente avec des actes
de violence qui sont mises en oeuvre
et puis par ailleurs des dérives de
milices pro iranienne qui ceux qui se
produisent ni vital vraisemblablement ce
qui s'est passé à erbil lierse était
hier soit volontairement significative
de ses moufles
non ça c'est le premier point donc pas
réparé dans le même ordre
dans la même logique que nous avons mis
en place un fonds de soutien aux
victimes des violences ethniques et
religieuses au moyen-orient dit que l'on
appelle le fond minorité de 35 millions
d'euros 5 millions d'euros par an pour
accompagner des projets concrets
principalement en irak mais également en
syrie au liban en jordanie en turquie et
nous nous prenons par ailleurs notre
part dans l'accueil des réfugiés et des
minorités menacées nous avons convenu
d'un accord
je souhaiterais pas trop rendre public
2 sur ce point si ça vous ennuie pas
avec la communauté de sant'egidio pour
faire en sorte que des corridors
humanitaires permettent d'accompagner de
manière digne des réfugiés syriens du
liban vers la france on le fait sans
faire trop d'ostentation est trop de
publicité mais on continuera à le faire
dans des créneaux qui sont pas toujours
faciles et non des modes de
fonctionnement qui sont parfois
dangereux mais ça se sont poursuis puis
nous avons accueilli sur notre sol une
centaine de familles zidi avec leurs
enfants
mais l'objectif ce n'est pas de
provoquer des migrations de chrétiens ou
de minorités vers la france métissée de
fer épices vivre dans les meilleures
conditions
là où ils vivent depuis depuis des
siècles et face à l'urgence il faut être
au rendez-vous mais fondamentalement il
faut essayer de faire en sorte que ces
minorités soient inclusives et puis
vivre sur les terres où elles ont eu
historiquement leur place parallèlement
à tout cela
nous avons intensifié notre soutien au
patrimoine des chrétiens et des autres
minorités d'orient
c'est un sujet important c'est un sujet
de référence j'ai moi même
il y a quelques jours visiter la
bibliothèque orientale de l'université
saint-joseph abbey road dont nous avons
assumé la reconstruction après les
dégâts causés par l'explosion du 4 août
deux derniers nous avons aussi
contribuer à la réhabilitation du
monastère de marbre denham qui est mise
en oeuvre par l'association française
fraternité en irak nous avons restauré
les templiers idée des tripes ardèche
dans la province de sinjar bref grâce à
anode intervention et en particulier
grâce à la naissance d'alif
l'association pour qui remet en état des
débats des bâtiments ou des éléments de
patrimoine détruit par la guerre par les
guerres 9a locale la france contribue à
hauteur de 30 millions de dollars
poursuivons notre
action pour la mise en oeuvre de la
protection des patrimoines des chrétiens
d'orient et nous allons essayer de faire
en sorte que cette association puisse
avoir une dimension européenne lors de
la présidence ce française c'est un des
objectifs que je me donne au moment de
la de la présidence française du premier
semestre 2022 fasse faire en sorte que
cette protection et de réhabilitation du
patrimoine soit partagée je pense qu'on
va pouvoir y arriver j'observe
d'ailleurs avec intérêt que la
présidente nommé du louvre madame
laurence des cars qui est actuellement
président du musée d'orsay mais qui va
prendre ses fonctions au louvre le 1er
septembre a décidé de mettre en oeuvre
rapidement le projet de création d'un
neuvième département dédié à byzance et
au christianisme orientaux ce qui est
une preuve aussi une bonne nouvelle donc
7,7 ce volet culturel et patrimonial de
notre action est indissociable de
soutien que nous apportons aux écoles
chrétiennes du proche orient
confronté à des difficultés financières
travers le fonds de soutien aux écoles
d'orient que l'on appelle souvent pour
faire faire vivre le faux personnage
puisque c'est le fonds est soutenu par
charles est présidée par charles
personnaz qui on avait proposé la mise
en place dans le rapport que vous
connaissez la création avait été
annoncée par le président a prouvé qu'en
janvier 2020 à jérusalem
il y avait une structure de
préfiguration et maintenant le travail a
commencé le l'été dernier
avec une part égale d'un million d'euros
de l'oeuvre d'orient et d'un million
d'euros de l'état qui nous permettent de
financer des projets de restauration des
locaux et des soutiens aux organisations
caritatives et poussant pour cueillir de
vraie mobilisation autour de tout cela
et je profite pour saluer la sénatrice
christine navarre qui est membre du
conseil d orientation et qui s'y
investit beaucoup
le conseil d'orientation de ce fonds va
se réunir vendredi prochain devrait
maintenant passer en revue les
situations dans les différents pays
avant que nous puissions échanger sur
tous ces sujets d'abord commençant par
le liban où il y avait justement urgence
à soutenir les quelques trente
établissements chrétiens du réseau
homologué de l'enseignement français à
l'étranger il ya 55 établissements qui
sont homologués et que dans lesquelles
il ya trente établissements chrétiens et
plus largement il y à 3 133
établissements chrétien francophone ou
enseignant le français au liban qui
accueille 190 mille enfants et qui
constitue le plus gros contingent
d'établissement de cette nature dans la
région pour mémoire on en compte 90 en
egypte 47 en israël 30 en palestine 40
en jordanie ici sort turquie pour un
total évalué à 400 mille élèves alors en
raison de la crise économico politique
sur laquelle on verra peut-être qui
frappe le liban et l'explosion du 4 août
dernier
ce patrimoine éducatif extrêmement
précieux qui est aussi un élément
essentiel de nos politiques d' influence
au service des valeurs de la
francophonie fait s'est trouvée menacée
par toutes ces perturbations et nous
avons mobilisé près de 25 millions
d'euros qui sont et qui ont été mises à
la disposition des établissements
français et francophones et des familles
libanaises et dont 21 millions d'euros
depuis la rentrée 2020 pour le réseau
est homologué plus le fonds dirigé par
charles personnaz qui dans lesquelles
près de 2 millions d'euros volés aux
écoles francophones chrétienne du liban
et maintenant en raison de la gravité de
la situation nous avons décidé d'ouvrir
à titre exceptionnel en 2021 la
possibilité d'adhérer scolarité pour les
élèves de ces établissements et pourrait
prendre qu'un seul exemple j'ai pu me
rendre compte dans mon dernier
déplacement au liban qui était il ya peu
de temps
je suis allé au collège dès 5 heures 5
heures
c'était il ya deux mois j'ai pu
constater la manière dont ce collège
avait pu bénéficier des aides à la
reconstruction de zz aux familles des
aides aux projets pédagogiques
pédagogique alors que il avait été
extrêmement endommagé par par la crise
le par l'explosion du port de bayonne va
dire aussi que sur les affaires
libanaises l'on fasse j'imagine qu'on va
reparler mais puisque pour rester sur la
partie de chrétiens d'orient je
m'entretiens très régulièrement avec le
cardinal rail cardinal patriarche
maronite du liban avec une une pour
échanger sur le thème si la situation
politique sur lequel nous nous avis
concordent mais malheureusement notre
impuissance est souvent partagée mais je
dis pas ce que j'ai pu lire comme vous
des articles des interviews du cardia
dry dans la presse française il ya
quelques jours sur la situation en
jordanie
les chrétiens se voir reconnaître
d'égalité devant la loi et la liberté de
culte et la monarchie hachémite
s'attache à porter un discours de
tolérance de coexistence pour les jeux
sur la scène régionale et internationale
nous nous les aidons dans le cas du
fonds minorité que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure nous soutenons plusieurs projets
menés par les églises du patriarcat
latin en jordanie et par caritas en
faveur de en particulier des réfugiés
irakiens afin de favoriser leur
intégration économique et puis dans le
cadre du fonds de soutien aux écoles
d'orient diffon personnaz nos jours nous
avons pu aussi intervenir sur plusieurs
projets de modernisation des
établissements
jeudi quelques noix c'est la situation
est relativement sereine je dit quelques
mots sur l'egypte où nous
sommes résolument engagés ou kader aux
côtés des autorités égyptiennes dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme qui a souvent
endeuillée la grande communauté des
chrétiens d'orient
parce que c'est l'oeuvre commune de la
plus importante où il ya entre 6 et 7
millions de coptes
oui d'une série d'attentats barbares qui
ont marqué les consciences
comme vous le savez le pape à l'adresse
de a été reçue à paris par le poison de
république en octobre 2019
moi même je l'occasion de visiter à
plusieurs reprises et nous sommes dans
une mobilisation active de soutien
auprès de la population copte mais
j'observe je vais dit en commençant
l'attitude positive des autorités
égyptiennes ça nous empêche pas de dire
aux egyptiens et vos propre résidence
ici qu il y a aussi d'autres respect des
droits de l'homme que nous attendons de
la part des autorités égyptiennes
l'un n'empêche pas l'autre mais en même
temps constatons que sur la communauté
copte
il y a eu dans antérieurement des
positions différentes de celles qui sont
aujourd'hui
effectuée par par le président les
autorités égyptiennes par leur président
si ce jeudi deux mots sur la syrie avant
de passer aux autres secteurs pour y ait
pas d'ambiguïté entre nous j'espère
qu'il n'a pas enfin autant autant se le
dire nous nous ne sommes pas en
situation de d'avoir à l'égard de la
syrie
une attitude positive tant qu'il n'y
aura pas eu un règlement politique
quand je dis nous c'est pas nous la
france c'est nous l'ensemble des acteurs
de la cohésion contre dèche
je vous le dis parce que nous sommes
réunis spécialement aussi sur la
question syrienne
toujours dans le 2ème cycle de réunions
de rome et nous considérons que en
l'absence de solution politique
les mêmes causes continueront à
provoquer les mêmes effets et le risque
d'une résurgence de dèche du terrorisme
restera présent en syrie donc nous
estimons qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre la
résolution 22 54 du conseil de sécurité
quand je dis nous c'est l'ensemble des
acteurs qui sont acteurs de cette action
y compris évidemment les européens les
américains et les pays les pays du golfe
qui sont partie prenante
je vous rappelle mais vous le savez
qu'aujourd'hui plus de la moitié de la
population syrienne est déplacée en
france et en sirote qu'en syrie soit 6
millions de déplacés en syrie cinq
millions de réfugiés hors syrie mais il
seule une solution politique et
inclusive pourra permettre de donner des
garanties solides dans l'ensemble des
minorités et jeudi que souvent à ceux
qui ont oublié que c'est bien bachar el
assad qui a libéré de ses prisons les
éléments qui ont encadré
mouvement des shows le mouvement al ne
sera au moment où ils avaient besoin de
réaffirmer son autorité je suis bien
placé pour le savoir étant à ce moment
là ministre de la défense je rajoute
aussi mais que nous restons concernant
la syrie mobilisés avec nos partenaires
de la coalition et avec nos partenaires
locaux des forces démocratiques
syriennes notamment avec nos partenaires
kurdes dans le nord-est syrien pour
empêcher dans cette partie de la syrie
parce que c'est la plus de risques la
résurgence de d'âge tout en disant qu'il
faut être très précautionneux dans cette
affaire parce que tant la sabine la
stabilité est là c'est bien mais dans le
nord-est syrien vous avez sur un espace
extrêmement restreint tout le monde vous
avez les russes vous avez lecture vous
avez les kurdes
vous avez un peu de français vous avez
des irakiens vous avez des ch vous avez
tout le monde et tout le monde se croise
donc il faut absolument s'assurer
s'assurer de la sécurité des lieux parce
que il y à des zones des prisons des
camps et avec les des risques de
résurgence de dèche et si on n'est pas
qu'on n'a pas à assurer une sécurité
totale de la zone
vous avez aussi des américains de toutes
tous les acteurs sont présents dans des
culs espace très restreint
je vais vous dire quelques mots sur eux
sur l'irak
j'en ai parlé en commençant où nous
importe vraiment que la
la crise irakienne puisse aboutir à une
intégration et une politique inclusive
où chaque communauté puisse trouver sa
place à commencer évidemment par la
communauté kurde avec laquelle nous
avons des relations régulières je suis
là il ya très peu de temps monsieur nati
revendre barzani à à paris je lui dis
aussi l'importance de notre coopération
sur le plan sur le plan sécuritaire et
souhaitait aussi avancé avec lui sur le
renforcement de notre coopération dans
le domaine sanitaire en particulier
l'appui à l'hôpital de la dja dans la
dja pardon qui avait été qui dédie aux
victimes de la taxe chimiques de mars 88
les gens sont toujours à mener et
soigner en raison de le drame qu'ils ont
connue à l'époque mais en irak nous
sommes aussi en relation avec la
communauté yazidie avec
aussi la volonté de relever la raison de
la région du sinjar en irak et soutient
avec madame nadia mourad qu il était à
paris
on a vu encore il ya trois jours pour
faire en sorte que je en particulier le
nouvel hôpital ouvert à toutes les
communautés puissent devenir le vrai
chantier emblématique que nous voulons
faire valoir les travaux ont commencé
c'est un engagement que la france a pu
respecter malgré les complications y
compris sécuritaire dans la zone il est
parfaitement pacifique sur les
territoires palestiniens les chrétiens
qui représentait 20% les palestiniens en
1948 ne sont plus aujourd'hui que de 1
2% de la population israélienne et
palestinienne je le disais je le disais
en commençant c'est une des grosses
difficultés sur la longue durée
ils sont 150 milles en israël 50 à 60
milles dans les territoires palestiniens
dont moins de 20000 dans l'agglomération
de bethléem 10000 à jérusalem est et
2000 à gaza le rôle est
traditionnellement très important dans
la société et la vie politique
palestinienne et malgré leur identité
très forte de chrétiens de terre sainte
il souffre d'une double marginalisation
d'une part d'un statut de minoritaire de
plus en plus affirmée notamment dans les
parties des territoires palestiniens les
plus marquées par l'islam politique et
d'autre part l'occupation et la
colonisation israélienne et touche au
même titre que les autres palestiniens
mais je n'oublie pas dans ce contexte
l'importance symbolique et est
religieuse que revêt jérusalem pour les
trois religions du livre
je voudrais rappeler ici puisque c'est
là aussi ça fait aussi partie je pense
de vos préoccupations que la france a
hérité de l'histoire un rôle spécifique
auprès des chrétiens palestiniens et
israéliens et qui illustrent plus
largement ses liens historiques avec les
chrétiens d'orient tout ça remonte au
capitulation de 1536 mais nous avons un
rôle de protection des lieux saints de
garantie du libre accès de ces dieux aux
chrétiens nous avons un rôle de
protection de certaines communautés
religieuses d'origine française établie
en terre sainte en raison de désaccords
dix accords de mytilène en 1901
reconduit par l'accord franco israélien
dit chauvel fischer de 1948 et enfin que
nous avons la propriété de quatre sites
relevant du domaine national dans trois
sites sont chrétiens l'église sainte
anne en vieille-ville que les poseurs
publica a visité en janvier dernier
l'église du pater noster dit de et
léonard et le monastère d'abou koch qui
est située en israël et dans ce contexte
puisque vous parliez sur président tout
à l'heure du consul général de france à
jérusalem que vous avez reçu ce jour et
saluer tout particulièrement la mémoire
de l'ambassade de france jean gueguen ou
récemment disparu depuis avant de
devenir ambassadeurs auprès du saint
siège avait occupé les fonctions de
consul général de france à jérusalem est
qui resta toute sa vie immobilisée par
la mission de la france auprès des
chrétiens des chrétiens d'orient et il a
une action tout à fait tout à fait
remarquable que je voulais saluer lors
de cette audition
voilà voilà les pour moi l'essentiel de
ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction nous nous sommes tout à
fait déterminés à poursuivre notre
action et des avancées il ya des aussi
des situations toujours au très très
périlleuse qui demeure et
nous allons devons aussi éviter un
risque mais je crois que chacun ici le
pré sensé il ne faut pas que nous
puissions identifier notre politique d'
influence uniquement en direction des
des minorités notamment des chrétiens
comme s'ils étaient étrangers dans leur
propre pays et comme licite et des
communautés séparées soutenu par les
occidentaux alors qu'ils font partie du
tissu social de moyen-orient depuis deux
millénaires
il faut pas que nous puissions être
suspecté d'une telle d'une telle logique
qui n'est pas celle que nous que nous
souhaitons mais c'est donc aux états de
la région qu'incombe la responsabilité
première de protéger les droits des
chrétiens d'orient et des membres des
autres minorités d'en faire des citoyens
à part authier à part entière dans les
sociétés auxquelles ils appartiennent
c'est pourquoi nous veillons a toujours
associé les états de nos efforts et les
pousser à prendre leurs responsabilités
et à prendre des initiatives à cet égard
je constate que certains pays ça a été
le cas depuis 2019
il faut poursuivre en ce sens par votre
action par notre action par notre
présence et par notre volonté partagée
j'en ai fini pour la merci monsieur le
ministre pour ce tableau très contrastée
de la situation et des chrétiens et des
et des minorités
c'était utile que vous rappeliez
l'action de la france qui se déroulent
et s'établit dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile
il est d'autant plus difficile que
lorsque nous avons nous-mêmes reçu ici
bien sûr autour du président larcher
les principales d'autorité religieux je
pense notamment au cardinal rails il
nous a supplié de ne pas organisé de
rapatriement ou
deux de ces chrétiens car le premier
réflexe est de dire on va les accueillir
et 10 mai si vous les accueillez ça veut
dire qu'on les rires à de la carte et le
but de toute action vise au contraire de
leur redonner des conditions de vie et
de sécurité qui leur permettent de vivre
là où leurs racines les les imposer donc
c'est très très difficile effectivement
et vous avez aussi souligné à mon sens
l'élément important de l'action de la
france vis à vis des établissements
scolaires je crois que là il faut
véritablement soigner ce point le
président retailleau merci cher
président christian cambon merci d'avoir
fait cette introduction par de démonter
remercie monsieur le ministre de vous
prêter à cette audition qui est commune
entre notre commission permanente et et
le groupe que j'ai l'honneur de présider
qui est l'un des plus importants groupe
de liaison pour les chrétiens d'orient
mais aussi les minorités je voudrais
redire ce qui était en filigrane dans
votre discours que la présence de ces
minorités chrétiens et autres concernent
d'identité concerne l'histoire mais
aussi l'avenir de ces pays
j'ai souvent utilisé une métaphore entre
l'abeille l'environnement et ses
minorités et et la paix dans ce pays
ces minorités la présence de ces
minorités sont finalement pour ces pays
ce que ce que la bei est à
l'environnement elles sont des témoins
souvent de la santé cilic
si j'ose dire et et de la concorde peu
civile aussi dans ce nid dans sept pays
et par exemple pour une communauté que
je connais bien les chrétiens d'orient
souvent ils assurent eux mêmes une forme
de passerelles y compris entre les
sunnites et les chiites dans un certain
nombre de pays pour des raisons
historiques t raison si culturel que je
veux souligner et je ne reviens pas sur
le cadre que vous avez rappelé les
relations historiques les
responsabilités que nous avons aussi
particulière de la france vis-à-vis de
ces communautés et notamment des
chrétiens d'orient je me concentrais
très rapidement sur quatre ou cinq
points avec des questions
d'abord pour le liban vous avez cité la
sénatrice qui est la présidente
christine lagarde qui préside le groupe
d'amitié et avec quelques sénateurs elle
se rendra nous nous rendrons au liban
dont dans quelques dans quelque temps le
pays est en train de s'effondrer
et c'est pas faute de la volonté de la
france de le redresser
face à cet effondrement on risque de
perdre des infrastructures au sens du
service public essentiel
je veux parler de la santé je veux
parler de l'éducation charles personnaz
a écrit je pense qu'il vous a envoyé une
copie au président de la république pour
lui faire part d'une idée que nous
souhaitons pousser soutenir qui serait
qu' il y ait une agence des bailleurs
internationaux ce qui pourvoit l'aide
internationale puisqu'il ya la
corruption
cette agence recueillerait cette aide là
pour que elles ne sortent pas pour être
c'est pour s'évaporer ensuite et qu' on
puisse directement payer des salaires
sur ces deux réseaux le réseau de santé
et les réseaux éducation parce que 6e
il sait qu'il s'écroule avec
l'effondrement général ce sera très
difficile de reconstruire le pays et ça
pour la population c'est capital ça me
semble être une idée qui est bonne
positive
pas trop compliqué à mettre en place et
qui pourrait être je pense très utile je
voudrais avoir votre analyse monsieur le
ministre
ensuite deux du liban je vais passer en
syrie parce que le prince du liban c'est
aussi le très classieux deux millions
deux millions de réfugiés
c'est comme si en france on avait mes
chers collègues 20 millions de réfugiés
vous imaginez et même peut-être plus
mais vous imaginez la proportion pour un
pays qui est en train de s'effondrer
d'avoir à soutenir cette proportion de
réfugiés donc une réfugiée de syriens au
liban et voilà enfin ça fait la
proportion s'est à peu près 20 millions
1 donc la stabilisation du du la syrie
est important j'attire votre attention
sur un sujet qui est important puisque
nous sommes à trois jours d'un délai
vous savez pour la résolution 7 10
juillet sur les corridors humanitaires
dans le nord-ouest du pays
on est très préoccupée puisque les
risques pour les russes pourraient
opposer
un veto au conseil de sécurité et on est
très concerné sur l'accès de bab al hawa
qui ne pourrait ne pas être renouvelé si
c'est le cas c'est plus d'un million
personnes qui vivent dans le nord-ouest
du pays qui seront privés des devis
talent et qui seront en grand danger
voilà donc première question sur la
syrie qu'est ce que la france pourrait
contribuer à faire sur ce point
particulier le second c'est bien entendu
pour stabiliser
qu'est ce qui empêche certes c'est un
criminel vous le savez mais j'imagine
que parmi les personnalités vous croisez
parfois certaines ont du sang sur les
mains et la diplomatie ne consiste pas
uniquement à dialoguer avec des seins ou
avec des gens qui sont qui prennent le
thé à 17 heures je pense qu'à un moment
donné il ya une un dialogue à prendre je
ne sais pas quelle forme il peut prendre
vous pouvez vous même nous dire quel
quelles conditions qui pourraient être
levés pour que ce dialogue constructif
pas pour reconnaître tel ou tel mais
pour essayer d'aider un pays
là encore à se relever pour ce qui
concerne l'irak
vous avez souligné donc la visite était
importante de jean-paul de sa visite sa
rencontre avec l'ayatollah ali sistani
qui est qui et chiite comme vous le
savez c'est cet important on a tous vu
ces affiches qui était incroyable entre
ces deux personnalités se donnant la
main je pense que c'est cette aide de
très belles des très belles images
propres à restaurer un peu de paix
civile
ma question sur sur l'irak c est ce que
puisque le retrait militaire américain
se poursuit ou est-ce qu'on en ait
vraiment par rapport à l'administration
maiden est ce que cette la poursuite est
toujours engagé ou est-ce qu'on en est
notamment des cellules dormantes et de
la sécurité il ya eu le trac de drones
ça pourrait signer sur erbil ça pourrait
signer une iranienne je sais pas vous
nous direz peut-être mais sur l'irak
qu'elle est calé sur le plan de la
sécurité votre votre analyse
avant dernier point sur le patrimoine je
suis très heureux que vous ayez pu
souligner ce cet aspect là d'où les
totalitarismes et le totalitarisme
islamiste n'y a pas coupé
mais dans l'histoire tous les
totalitarismes se sont toujours sur sont
toujours pris la culture parce que la
culture c'est l'âme des peuples et dans
la volonté farouche d'éliminer les
peuples n'ya jusqu'à éliminer la trace
de l'histoire de l'identité culturelle
de ces peuples
c'est important nous avons tenu ici même
il ya quelques jours une table-ronde
importantes sur la question de la
préservation du patrimoine avec la leaf
avec monsieur martinez et haute je pense
que c'est fondamental il n'y aura pas de
reconstruction matérielle
s'il n'y a pas une reconstruction aussi
immatériel c'est la condition aussi de
la reconstruction matérielle de ce point
de vue là nous avons aussi accueilli la
successeure prochaine de jean luc
martinez au louvre qui va créer ce
département consacré aux chrétiens
d'orient et je voudrais vous dire aussi
que nous avons bien accueilli la
nomination comme ambassadeur chargé de
la préservation du patrimoine naba
monsieur jean luc martinez à partir je
crois de la rentrée je pense que c'est
une bonne chose et il faut soutenir alif
non seulement parce que sa vice
présidente est une ancienne sénatrice
que vous connaissez bien et que nous
aimons beaucoup mais ali fait un travail
fantastique
le monastère de mar behnam et d'ailleurs
de ce point de vue là un symbole puisque
il est un lieu consacré vénéré à la fois
par les i die par les musulmans mais
aussi par les chrétiens je pense que la
culture est un lien au sein d'une même
d'un même groupe civilisationnel
religieux mais mais peut-être aussi
entre différents groupes et et c'est
quelque chose absolument fondamental je
terminerais pour vous dire je comptais
vous questionner sur la conférence
internationale sur les victimes de
violences ethniques et religieuses
la dernière c'était bruxelles j étais il
ya trois ans je suis tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'elle se tienne
prochainement à bagdad
mais il ne faudrait pas mais j'y suis
favorable mais je ne voudrais pas voyez
que l'on tienne si fort à ce lieu
symbolique h
deux raisons que l'on manque encore une
amie je préférerais encore qu'elles se
tiennent à paris ou ailleurs mais
qu'elle se tienne
voyez même si je comprends parfaitement
les raisons mais bien mais je suis
d'accord mais je suis absolument
d'accord
simplement il faut il faut qu'elle soit
à bagdad un jour et même politiquement
si mais voilà vous y répondre et un mot
sur le fonds de soutien
on la vide un peu disparaître des
éléments budgétaires 5 millions c'est
assez peu ça a été vraiment un levier
extrêmement puissant moi j ai participé
j'y participe le pourquoi mais vous avez
aidé des ong
il ya eu un effet de levier avec des des
choses très concrètes qui ont échappé à
la corruption et je pense qu'il faudrait
renforcer ce fonds réassocier les ong
réassocier quelques élus parce que je
pense que c'est important ça nous permet
notamment de participer à l'effort de
relèvement commun vis-à-vis de ses
minorités
merci monsieur le ministre oui je
propose que le ministre répond tout de
suite à bruno retailleau puis après je
me prendrai les questions d'abord sur le
sur le liban je note bien la proposition
de lagence de bailleurs
et nous allons étudier cette proposition
qui lui paraît a priori intéressante
sous réserve qu'elle soit bien bien
orienté vous l'avez souligné sur le
sanitaire et l'éducatif
parce que il ne faudrait pas c'est pas
le cas mais il ne faut il ne faudrait
pas que la capacité je parle avec
pondération passe comme ces publics
et comme généralement lorsque je le dis
pour tous ceux qui vont écouter lire
dans cette salle quand je dis deux mots
sur le liban ça fait la une de l'orient
le jour
mais s'ils peuvent recommencer c'est ça
ne gêne pas mais il faut donc être très
mesurées sur ce qu'on dit je redis que
il n'y a pas d'échappatoire possible
pour les libanais il faut qu'ils se
dotent d'un gouvernement et donc
j'ai bien entendu le premier ministe
transitoire par intérim au que monsieur
diab faire ses déclarations hier pour
dire ne nous laissez pas tomber
parce que nous sommes dans des
situations très difficiles y compris au
niveau humanitaire
oui c'est vrai mais ça fait un an et
demi qu'on vous dit les uns et les
autres
pas uniquement le ministre de l'europe
des affaires étrangères les uns et les
autres de la communauté internationale y
compris récemment mon collègue brinken
des états unis doté vous d'un
gouvernement
sinon rien ne sera possible et la
communauté internationale ne sera au
rendez vous financier que si vous vous
doter d'un gouvernement
et on sait que c'est possible il ya un
premier ministre désigné et on sait où
sont les blocages et donc moi je suis
pas opposé à ce qui est parallèlement à
cela des actions d'accompagnement de la
population libanaise qui souffrent mais
les responsabilités on les a bien
identifié et je vais je rappelle
représentants des différents courants
politiques libanais que
ils ont promis juré le 1er septembre
dernier et
à la résidence des pins de constituer un
gouvernement dans les quinze jours ils
étaient tous autour de la table comme
cela avec le président de la république
et on a fait le tour on a demandé à
chacun on est bien d'accord dans les
quinze jours un gouvernant techniciens
dont le but est de commencer les
réformes que tout le monde attend de la
part des autorités libanaises et de
faire en sorte qu'ils les élections en
en 2022
ces rendez vous là ne sont pas tenues et
donc le drame libanais et là nous allons
faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
conférence humanitaire qui va se tenir à
celle 20 juillet je vous donnais plus de
la conférence humanitaire qui va se
tenir le 20 juillet qui va permettre de
rassembler des fonds parce qu'il donne
le l'aide humanitaire doit être aussi au
rendez vous mais ce pays est tellement
de possibilités qui ne va pas continuer
à vivre uniquement sur une sur l'aide
humanitaire même si nous avons la
responsabilité de l'organiser donc je
prends volontiers la cette observation
de la proposition de lagence sûr mais
qui doit concerner que certains secteurs
et pas et est pas être amené une nexus
de plus pour les vents vin je vais
regarder ce sujet jamais cessé pas
inintéressant donc voilà je le dis avec
beaucoup de force sur le liban c'est
dramatique
peut-être pouvoir on va pas on va
peut-être bientôt être da à 1 an de de
là l'explosion du port à ma connaissance
le l'anc est toujours pas abouti
le monde
le ministre délégué auprès de moi franck
riester va se rendre à beyrouth dans
quelques jours pour uniquement sur les
questions de ses des questions
techniques et et portuaire bref c'est la
situation est vraiment dramatique il
faut contre l'opinion publique
internationale se réveille sur le sur le
sujet la nouveauté
je crois que c'est que le secrétaire
d'état américain dean cain a pris des
positions ont pu ça a été d'ailleurs
dans les journaux nous rencontrer
ensemble avec notre collègue saoudien ya
quelques jours il y à là a maintenant
j'espère une dynamique qui va se
poursuivre et j'aurai l'occasion de d'en
reparler avec lui avec lui la semaine
prochaine à washington
bon on va essayer de créer c'est cette
dynamique de forte plat la difficulté
c'est que les les acteurs qui étaient
antérieurement parties prenantes au
liban maintenant s'en désintéressent ces
mêmes traumatique
voilà en fait je m'excuse chaussures
toujours un peu ému en parlant de la
situation au liban parce que ça devient
vraiment insupportable sur sur la syrie
sur les corridors
alors je pense qu'il faudrait l'idéal
serait d'avoir une d'avoir une carte ne
savez il ya il y a plusieurs
plusieurs corridors humanitaires qui
était prévu il y en a quatre
il y en a deux au nord ouest dont
bab al hawa eux
qui toujours ouvert il y avait aussi bab
al salam avant il y en a au sud la
frontière avec la jordanie
dia mais honnêtement ce corridor n'a pu
tellement d'intérêt parce que c'était il
n'ya plus vraiment de réfugiés dans
cette partie 2 de la série
et puis il ya un autre corridor entre le
corps et le corridor d'un deuil je relis
mon papier parce qu'il ya roubia équipe
le corridor au nord-est entre l'irak et
la syrie
dans cette partie donc j'évoquais tout à
l'heure nous sommes en discussion
actuellement sur l'ouverture humanitaire
cette discussion va se poursuivre au
conseil de sécurité
il se trouve que c'est la france qui
préside le conseil de sécurité depuis le
1er juillet je vais moi même présidé le
conseil en or personne pendant plusieurs
jours la semaine prochaine
donc on va essayer de faire avancer ce
dossier c'est la responsabilité d'abord
en la matière est une responsabilité
russe et j'espère qu'on pourra faire en
sorte qu liés nous nous battons sur
trois ouvertures
j'espère qu'on va réussir à faire en
sorte que soient maintenues c'est un
vrai combat mais qui est essentiel pour
assurer l'aide humanitaire aux
populations aux population syrienne en
particulier qui sont aujourd'hui les
victimes dans la partie nord nord ouest
la partie nord-est gelé un peu exprimé
exposé tout à l'heure c'est une partie
assez très compliqué on pourrait presque
avoir une carte en permanence devant soi
pour bien identifier où sont les parcs
les zones tenues par tel ou tel groupe
pour l'instant il ya une stabilité je
répondais bonne indication n'avait pas
posé mais c'était en arrière-plan
j'imagine
le fait que les états unis restent sur
la zone évite des confrontations turcot
kurde régime kurdes
ou présence russe intempestives bref on
est en situation de stabilité pour
l'instant même est très très complexe
parce qu il y a plusieurs milliers de
combattants de neige qui sont dans des
camps ou dans des prisons plusieurs
milliers là on parle souvent des
combattants français ils lassés par
dizaines là je parle de milliers qui
sont suite aux combats qui se sont
produits dans cette partie de la
bastille et des cas dans cette partie de
la de la syrie de l'iran à la frontière
avec l'irak ce donc le web non moi il
faudrait c'est là par la partie la
partie la partie nord-est mairie train
d'exposer spécifique spécifiquement la
pas mais c'est mais pour l'instant c'est
une situation de stabilité
la situation politique syrienne n'est
pas encore au rendez vous je les ai dit
tout à l'heure alors on sait bien qu'il
faudra une solution qui sera pas un
modèle complet de démocratie mais il
faudrait une solution politique
tant qu'il n'y a pas de solution
politique la communauté internationale
sa majorité en face ceux qui se sont
réunis à rome la semaine dernière ont
décidé de ne pas bouger sur la
reconstruction ni sur le réacheminement
des réfugiés
que syriens qui sont en partie vous avez
souligné le président qui en avait 2
millions au liban puis c'est un pays qui
accueillent ces populations et pas c'est
pas d'ailleurs dans des camps souvent
locales le cas aussi de la jordanie
c'est des populations qui se mélangent
là à la population de départ de du liban
donc les gens qui sont accueillis par
des cousins des voisins etc
mais ça se traduit évidemment par une
appétence d'école l'appétence de
scolarité n'a pas d'emploi c'est c'est
le cas au liban c'est le cas aussi en
jordanie mais il faut une solution
politique
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas au rendez
vous peut-être que les élections qui ont
eu lieu récemment sur les élections
truquées complètement et donc ne peuvent
pas servir de solution politique nations
unies ont d'un mandat t1
l'envoyé spécial monsieur paterson qui
essaye de trouver le moyen dans les
discussions qui ont lieu à genève de
passer à une autre étape mais pour
l'instant il ya une obstruction russe
qui nous permet pas beaucoup d'avancé
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur ce
point mais votre vigilant sur les
corridors elle est largement partagé sur
sur l'irak
bon je pense qu'il était souhaitable
qu'il y ait des élections
on n'a pas à prendre position sur la
qualité des autorités politiques mais
tout le problème actuel a essayé de
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un apaisement
on l'a reçu à paris a peu de temps
il faut maintenant attendre que le
processus prend à jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
son terme pour faire en sorte surtout
d'avoir une unification des dispositifs
de sécurité une relation correcte
potentiel avec le kurdistan
le kurdistan irakien nous entretenons
des relations très suivies et très
positive avec le méro présentant du
kurdistan irakien
mais aussi avec les autorités irakiennes
la france est une grande carte à jouer
là nous sommes crédibles par rapport à
l'ensemble des acteurs irakien nous
accompagnant leur leur volonté
d'inclusion
[Musique]
il y as difficultés de la mise en oeuvre
d'une unité militaire de sécurité en
particulier le peuvent faire en sorte
que les milices de la mobilisation
populaire ne perturbe pas le processus
d'intégration
il y à du côté des autorités religieuses
chiites des discours plutôt positif que
vous ayez pu vous même constaté monsieur
le président maintenant on souhaite que
ces élections puissent se dérouler dans
les meilleures conditions nous en ferons
des observateurs pour que se déroule
bien et je souhaite qu'après on puisse
avec des nouvelles autorités
faire en sorte que cette conférence que
soutenir je pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'à
se tiennent au proche orient au
moyen-orient et le mieux bloquent le
site le plus adapté c'est effectivement
bagdad sur le patrimoine
vous avez tous dit ce qu'il convenait de
dire que j'ai fait j'ai indiqué dans mon
exposé combien nous étions attachés à la
préservation de ce patrimoine à la
reconstruction des sites qui ont pu être
détruit par autres différents événements
et cette volonté se creuse poursuivra
grâce à la leaf que nous voulons étendre
dans sa dimension financière par une
participation européenne plus forte
j'espère que nous serons au rendez vous
je pense que devrait pouvoir aboutir à
cela
enfin et enfin le dernier point que sur
le fonds de soutien nous l'avons engagé
mais je pense que il est significatif le
maintenant
l'afd vrai aussi rentrer en ligne de
compte pour ces sujets satisfaites
le président cambon et donc nous allons
faire en sorte qu' il puisse est aussi
abondé mais de toute façon moi je suis
prêt à regarder comment on peut
renforcer le fonds minorité si il a
besoin d'être abondée mais nous sommes
au rendez vous des 5 millions d'euros
régulier donc je ne déroge pas sur ses
obligations budgétaires y compris au
dernier budget
[Musique]